be sure to follow me on Twitter there
you can keep up with all the updates
from comics explained and talk to me
directly
what's going on guys this is Rob and
after going through the comments for my
video on the Infinity stones from the
comics there seem to be a lot of
questions relating to the Infinity
stones in the movies and so in an effort
to clear up this confusion what we're
going to be doing is we're going to be
running through the Infinity stones in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe now before
we start this video there are a couple
things I want to run over the first is
that if you're interested in how Thanos
gained the Infinity stones in the comics
and how the Infinity Gauntlet event
unfolds I have those videos as a
playlist that'll be down in the
description now the second is that while
the Infinity stones are referred to as
the infinity gems in the comics it's
really up to you in terms of what you
choose to call them but in this video
for the sake of simplicity I'm just
going to be referring to them as the
Infinity stones and so with that being
said let's jump into it so what the
Marvel Cinematic Universe tells us is
that the infinity gems came into
existence as a result of the actions of
the four cosmic entities the four cosmic
entities come in the form of death
entropy infinity and eternity now
eternity represents the expansion of the
universe itself the continued existence
and the I guess the physical
manifestation of the universe what the
universe is infinity is the expansion of
all things that currently exist in the
universe the ever growing presence of
the universe itself until such a time
when the universe will end whatever that
time happens to be now entropy and death
are the other side of eternity and
infinity where eternity and infinity
combined represent the expansion of life
and the universe entropy and death
represent the end of life and the
universe entropy represents destruction
entropy entropy represents the end of
the universe death of course represents
the concept of death now the fact that
mistress death is in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe tells us that she's
probably the driving force behind why it
is Thanos is doing everything and during
the in credit scene of the Avengers when
the other had told Thanos that to
attempt to conquer to defeat earth
superheroes would mean to court death
was not a metaphor that in fact death
does exist and that much like in the
comics fan
drive is to capture the affections of
mistress death now in terms of why it
was they created the infinity gems we
don't know we don't know why they made
them all we know is that the result was
that they did make them and so as we get
into the section about what the infinity
gems represent keep in mind this will be
very similar to our discussion with
regards to the comic books but what
we're going to do here is I'm going to
try to go ahead and highlight each
member I guess each one of the infinity
gems as we know what they are and talk
about how it is the infinity gems I
guess effect or now what kind of actions
can be committed by the person who
wields the gems
so the first Infinity stone is the mind
stone now the mind stone appears to be
represented by the sceptre of Loki but
this really hasn't been confirmed in the
film so far now what the mind gem does
is it allows its wielder to manipulate
control and read the minds of every
person or every being in existence in
the universe now this can be done
simultaneously meaning that every mind
in the universe can be read at the same
time by the wielder of the mind stone if
they choose to do so the next one is the
reality stone and the reality stone
really seems to be the favorite of most
everybody who loves the Infinity stones
now the reality stone seems to have been
introduced in Thor the dark world and
the form of the ether but again this
hasn't really been confirmed the reality
stone simply put allows its user to
manipulate the very fabric of reality
and even defy all existing laws of
physics now in the comics the reality
Jim was stated by Thanos to require an
extraordinarily powerful mind to harness
and control its power without actually
going insane so the fact that Jane
Foster and Malekith from the Dark Elves
were basically capable of wheeling this
gym or I guess wielding this stone and
utilizing it meaning that they didn't
actually go insane indicates this stone
may not actually be as powerful as it is
in the comics now the next stone is the
power stone and this was confirmed to
have been the orbit and guardians of the
galaxy now the power stone was shown to
have been wielded by the Celestials at
some point in the past now if you're
interested in learning more about the
Celestials I have a video on them that
you're welcome to check out but the
power stone grants its wielder unlimited
power by drawing on all energy that has
ever existed in the universe
currently does exist in the universe
or will ever exist in the universe and
so as such the power stone is really the
foundation for all of the other Infinity
stones meaning that the power stone has
to exist in order for the Infinity
stones to reach their full potential now
the final stone on our list is the space
stone and as we know the space stone was
represented in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as the tesseract now originally
the tesseract was thought to have been
the Cosmic Cube but this was actually
cleared up by Kevin Feige in an
interview with comingsoon.net which of
course again you'll find down in the
description but the space stone allows
us wielder to move anywhere through
space instantaneously and even occupy
all spaces at once meaning they can be
on multiple planets at the same time now
the way the tesseract or I guess the way
the space stone was used in the Avengers
indicates to us that it seemed to have
largely to spin like a portal system
that it opened portals and that was
really it but this could have been due
to the fact that Loki just didn't know
how to use it properly or it could have
been due to the fact that the the space
stone needs the power stone in order for
it to be able to be used to its full
potential again we haven't really had
this question answered yet but having
said all that what we know so far is
that
Thanos had previously been in possession
of the mine stone and that he'd actually
turned the mine stone over to Loki when
he learned that the space stone was on
the planet Earth and the hope was that
Loki was going to be able to use the
mind stone to gain the forces necessary
to attain the the the space stone and
then bring both of those stones to
Thanos but of course as we know Loki
failed and he was captured by the
Avengers and so here's the
million-dollar question here's the
question that I imagine a lot of you
guys really want to know what happens
when someone manages to take all six
Infinity stones place them on the
Infinity Gauntlet and then use it simply
put all hell breaks loose in the comics
Thanos gave us one of the most
spectacular demonstrations of
ass-kicking ever seen in the history of
Marvel Comics he obliterated half the
life in the universe he snapped his
fingers and half the life in the
universe was gone he went on to
single-handedly defeat the universe
most powerful superheroes without any
real effort then he turned around he
defeated and imprisoned all the cosmic
entities and then he became the singular
most powerful being in the history of
the Marvel Universe I guess within the
earth-616 universe anyway that was
that's what he didn't yeah there was
almost no way of stopping him but he was
stopped and how he was stopped is
something that I'll let you figure out
as you're watching my Infinity Gauntlet
series with that being said we're gonna
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later peace
you